- [Annabelle] Hello?
- Hey Annabelle, it's GaryVee.
(gasps)
- [Annabelle] God damn it Gary.
(hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
- Hey everybody.
This is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 238
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
It's windy as hell in New York.
I am filming Planet of
the Apps here in New York City
so that's been fun all day.
And we found a
quick 15 minute window,
and I decided to
bang out a call-in show.
So, we're gonna
get right into it.
I'm really enjoying
the format of the show.
I think a lot of
people have been enjoying it,
what's been going on?
The GaryVee shop.
I can put that link up there.
I've been asking
people to subscribe.
Subscribe to my YouTube,
we're doing more of that.
Put that up.
We're gonna do a whole
lot of editing up front here.
- [Andy] Released after this,
we're gonna release that
business meeting with Jordan.
- Oh, this business
meeting video is crazy.
Everybody
watching on Facebook Live,
the next post of this
business meeting I did.
Andy, who is fundamentally
numb to my content,
'cause he's been consuming it
24 hours a day for
the last several weeks.
What are you, stink?
What's going on?
Is the...
What...
(dial tone)
(dials number)
Let's see.
Just calling myself real quick.
(phone rings)
- Hey you've
reached Gary's phone.
I'm really glad
of listening to this,
because who the hell
leaves voicemails in 2015?
- '15?
(group laughter)
I'm two years behind.
I gotta... I'ma do that, too.
I'm gonna update.
Are we good? You need me?
You need me?
Does he need me?
Does... This trumps.
You don't need me?
Good. All right. Learn
how to dial the number.
All right, so.
The...
Sorry for the
up front banter that I know
a lot of you get excited about,
but good weekend.
Football sucks.
But the content is rolling.
The podcast,
a lot of good stuff.
What's it?
- [Chris] It's Sherman.
- Sherman. You're
giving Sherman that love?
- [Chris] Yeah.
- He's gonna freak.
(phone ringing)
Sherman's gonna
miss his big moment.
Sherman's gonna die.
- [Chris] Yep.
(phone ringing)
- Hello there, this is Sherman
from Principal and Tasteful.
- Not even giving
him the full shout out
for not being on the phone.
Yes, Ty?
- [Tyler] Nothing.
- Okay, good.
Let's go to the next one.
So, while there's down time,
Make that lower
while you're dialing.
(phone dialing)
I think that one of the things
that's really interesting
about the call-in
format is the context
of going back and forth.
To me, that's real,
really where the value
in the last episode came in,
and that I'm really
excited about for this one.
So, I'm interested.
What's going on Facebook?
- [Andy] I'm a little
concerned that it's saying,
"No audio." I might
have accidentally covering it.
I don't know.
I think we're good.
- Please check the....
(dial tone)
- Give me the phone.
I mean, listen,
you're out of a job.
This is what, how it works.
If you're not capable of the...
Oh God, I went even worse.
I went with somebody who put in
120983reze.
Like I was like, like
I'm gonna figure out that.
(dials number)
Dude, you're so good at
everything but
dialing a phone.
You've been crushing every task.
I'm taking over.
(phone rings)
I know you guys hate downtime,
so I'm just going fast.
This is how we're doing it.
- [Jeremy] Hello?
- Jeremy, this is GaryVee
and you're on the show.
- [Jeremy] Gary, you
totally made my day, man.
I've been a fan
of yours for so long.
I'm so happy to be
talking to you right now.
- I appreciate it.
Where are you from? LA?
- [Jeremy] Yeah,
I was born in Paris,
but I live in Los Angeles.
- Awesome, man. So,
what can I help you with?
- [Jeremy] Yeah, so, you know,
thanks to everything
I've learned from you
I've actually been able
to start building a career
for myself as a
social media consultant.
- Very nice.
- [Jeremy] And just helping,
you know,
mainly artists, actually.
Mainly artists
in current companies
with their
social media strategy.
And I've been trying to
transition into not just being
the only person in my business,
and building a
smaller agency around it
in the same way that you have
been pulled at the same way.
So that I'm not the only person
essentially doing the work,
- Okay.
- [Jeremy] And I'm really
struggling on finding
the right inflection point
and moment where I can kind of
jump ahead at this
scale to have a second person,
because I'm having a
really hard time making
two peoples' salary
on one person's time,
even with the fact
that I'm working, you know,
12-14 hour days
to get all this going
to the place that we need to go.
- Yeah, I mean,
look, it's a resource game.
If you don't have
the money to be able
form the second person,
let me give you a
good piece of advice.
First of all, amass
more money than you think,
because any
curve ball, anything.
You know, everybody wants to
get to scale way too soon.
It's only
predicated on your finances.
It's a chicken and egg game,
but everybody wants to
get to that second person
and start scaling, and
then they do it way too early,
and they create
more vulnerability.
People don't realize, once
you have that second person,
you're managing somebody else,
and that drains
resources as well.
So, I would tell you to
think in marathon terms.
How old is your business?
How long have you
been trying to do this?
- [Jeremy] I've been
trying to transition
for about a year and a half now.
But I've been freelancing
for three or four years.
- So, I mean, look,
it just comes down
to one of two decisions.
Either you have, you
save up enough money,
and you have the
resources to do it
and still have your lifestyle.
Or, have you
audited your lifestyle?
Where do you live?
- I actually live at home.
- Love you.
- So I had gone to college--
That's the perfect answer.
Dropped out of college.
- [Jeremy] To do my business
and write and everything.
So, I really don't
have many expenses.
I stopped traveling.
- So...
- [Jeremy] I'll
eat out occasionally.
- So here's your
next move. Charge more.
- [Jeremy] Yeah.
- Raise everything.
Raise your freelance.
Raise your social
media agency's fees.
Charge more.
- [Jeremy] Do you think
it makes sense to charge
ahead of the person?
Or is that just kind
of unfair to charge ahead
for a process that
would involve a second person?
- I think that
you need to hustle.
So I think the answer is,
I think you need to deliver
on what you charge people.
But let's remember...
- [Jeremy] Yeah.
- That the time is subjective.
- What if I, today,
said, "Screw VaynerMedia"
and I'm gonna
become a consultant.
I have a funny feeling
that my hourly fee
is more than yours.
- [Jeremy] Yeah, probably.
- So, you're thinking
about it too binary.
You're thinking about it--
- [Jeremy] Yeah.
- Multiple people, 80 hours.
Why don't you just
charge double for your hours?
- Right. Yeah.
I think that'll help
because the problem that
I'm having is essentially
what'll happen is,
I'll, you know, go out, sell
a lot, get a lot of clients,
and then I'll be stuck
fulfilling those clients,
unable to have the
time to keep selling...
- You're not charging enough.
- [Jeremy] Yeah, okay.
- That's it.
- [Jeremy] And so, just,
sorry, just one more.
So, on one of those
issues, mainly what I consult on
is story strategy and
kind of branding strategy.
I'm helping companies and artists
communicate their story
on what makes them different
to their audience, on the
different social platforms.
I've been wanting to move into
actually social management.
You obviously have way
more experience in doing that,
and I know that
it's a lot more work.
Do you think
there's a certain point
where that'll make more sense,
with a certain
number of employees?
Because I know being
alone, that will probably
eat up even more of the time
and not give me as value
- Yeah, I think,
I don't think you
can go down that route
of putting out content
and doing community management
until you have
more infrastructure,
'cause that's much more timely.
The fact that you're
stretched thin on something
that is as lofty and
theoretical and floaty
as brand strategy means
that you're very far away
from the scale that you'll
need for actual execution.
It's, you're selling ideas
right now, and conversations.
When you have to sell output,
it becomes a much
more difficult game.
- [Jeremy] Right. Okay.
Well, thank you very much.
- You got it, brother.
- [Jeremy] Seriously, I'm 23
and you've completely changed
my life in the last 4 years
that I've been following you.
- And real quick,
for everybody. How so?
When you say I've
changed your life,
has it been more
about the practicality?
What is the value prop?
- Yeah, I mean, I'll give you
a really specific example.
My biggest problem was
always discipline, right?
School was always
super easy for me.
- Right.
- So, I was a little,
kind of, not engaged with it,
until I got to college
and had to work super hard
and I started
putting 80, 100 weeks.
But that was really tough,
because I was
trying to balance so much.
And then after I dropped out,
I had no more structure.
So, I really never
had any discipline.
And it was
something I had to come by--
- Yep.
- [Jeremy] all by myself and
work ethic was always
the thing that
I thought I was worst at,
which is a really
bad thing to be bad at,
as much as I am driven
on stuff that
I really care about.
But this year, after
spending a lot of time
consuming your content
over the last year or so,
just, for the last
five weeks, I'll say,
I've just been in it nonstop.
And I think that work
ethic I've been able to develop
has kind of been
completely from watching you
and the amount that
you're relentlessly going at it.
And so I've been
able to build my business,
and build my work ethic, and
just be in it every single day
making the most
out of every day,
and actually getting
work done rather than saying,
"Oh, I can do it tomorrow."
Seizing even a moment,
even if somebody's late,
I'll just get some work done
really quickly between things.
- You basically...
- [Jeremy] I'm not, you
know, waiting for blocks.
- You basically just did the
commercial for DailyVee.
It's the single
reason I did DailyVee.
To eliminate any doubt of the
insanity it actually takes.
I appreciate it, brother.
I'm gonna move on.
Have a great day.
- [Jeremy] Yeah,
no worries. Sounds...
- Oops, sorry. I
hate cutting people off.
- What's that?
- [Andy] Facebook Live
have you seen this?
Tap to invite and him to
join your video as a guest.
Bringing guests on Facebook Live
- Yeah.
Yeah I saw that the
last time I was on as well.
It's work ethic man.
It is the variable that you can
absolutely be in charge of.
- [Jimmy] Hello?
- Jimmy this is GaryVee.
and you are on
The #AskGaryVee Show.
- [Jimmy] Gary,
that is awesome man.
- How you doing?
- [Jimmy] I am doing awesome.
How are you doing?
- Tremendous.
What can I answer for you?
- [Jimmy] I have a
question about travel blogging--
- Okay.
- [Jimmy] And I was
wondering if you can
expand on it a little bit.
Kind of like the reasons why.
I see a lot of travel blogs.
Tons of them around
that do their travel blog
under the name of their blog
and they advertise
everything on social networks
under the name of the blog
and stuff like that.
- Okay.
- [Jimmy] Would
you do a travel blog
under the name of a blog
or would you
develop a personal brand
within the travel space?
- I would develop
a personal brand
within the travel space
because one of the most
important vulnerabilities
that people
create for themselves
is they niche
themselves in the world as
I'm the southeast Asia guy.
And then it's four years later
and you want to
be the Europe guy
or you want to be
the basketball guy.
Building your
name is a much, much
better way to go.
Look what happened with me.
If my Twitter
handle was wine guy,
I would have had to go through
that branding transition.
And even without that,
just being Gary Vaynerchuk,
it was tough for me to become
a business
personality to hundreds
of thousands of people
because they had
me as a wine guy.
I always think
you develop your name
because life is long
and this is a forever game.
- [Jimmy] Right yeah.
And my main
reason for asking was
because it was,
it was more of a niche blog.
I was looking at something like
let's travel America
- Yep.
- [Jimmy] And looking at doing
and I about 97% sure
that I wanted to focus on U.S.
and domestic travel and stuff.
So that's why I was kind of
wondering to do
it under the name
or do it building--
- Build your name.
Build your name but
build up the show name too.
I have an #AskGaryVee Show.
and this and that.
There's GaryVee.
There's Gary Vaynerchuk.
This is where people over think.
But I do think your
name gives you flexibility.
- [Jimmy] Yeah, yeah.
It's been bothering me a lot.
- Well it shouldn't
bother you anymore.
It's over.
No more bothering.
Good?
- [Jimmy] I'm good man.
- Good man.
- [Jimmy] I'm good.
- Awesome.
(phone dialing)
No more bothering.
I mean, why are we
pondering on
things that don't matter?
Today's Instagram post
that I saw a lot of people
be emotional about,
going one for five
instead of oh
for oh is better.
And that's a
real thought. A lot of--
- [Michael] This is Michael.
- Michael, It's GaryVee.
You're on The #AskGaryVee Show.
- [Michael] What's up now?
- What is up now is that
you're on because you said,
"I'm ready with my
question." So don't bullshit me.
What's your question?
- [Michael] I'm
ready with my question.
- Go.
- [Michael] My question is you
posted and talked several times
about the chase, the pursuit.
How you love being on
the hunt, being on the game.
- Yep.
- [Michael] And specifically,
when it relates to vacation.
I've got a several
day vacation comin' up.
You've said that you
look forward to getting there,
but then when you get
there it's kind of like eh.
It doesn't really deliver on
what you hoped it would be.
You don't enjoy it as
much. My question to you,
you talk a lot
about the work ethic.
I know you're very intentional
with everything you do.
So, with the vacation,
what are you looking
to get out of that?
What are you looking to do?
What's your game plan
as you go into vacation?
- You know, I think
you're taking that in context
to some comment I probably
made in the last couple weeks,
which is like I struggle
with the relaxing part of it.
- [Michael] Yeah, specifically,
you were talkin' on Medium.
And my wife had
found this 'cause I think she
believes it to be
true of me as well.
She said, "Look at this post
from Gary Vaynerchuck on Medium.
"And he's talkin' about
when he goes to AJ's to watch
"a NFL draft party. He
doesn't enjoy the being there
"as much as he does the
looking forward to that."
And I feel like that's
how you feel about vacations.
- Oh, you know, I'm sorry.
- [Michael] And I think
that's really interesting.
- Oh, so let's play that out.
You're talking
about anticipation,
which is basically all I've got.
I think the
reason I'm winning is
'cause I love the
journey and anticipation
more than the
destination. By the way,
I've already
made a video that says
buying the New York Jets
is the worst day of my life.
Because that's the ultimate
destination game I'm playing.
Right?
- [Michael] Yep, yep.
- Oh, I know what
you're referring to, yeah.
When I land at
vacation, I get sad.
Because it was the
week leading up to vacation
because I love the
time with my family.
And I love having that break.
I'm already looking
forward to, right now,
I'm already
looking forward to the
last two weeks of August,
those two weeks in December.
I especically like vacation when
the whole world
is shut down, because
then I don't feel like
anybody's getting ahead of me.
I like that, so yeah,
I love anticipation.
I love the thrill of the hunt.
Even back to being in 5th grade.
I tried to get girls to like me,
but then I was still scared
of them 'cause I was too young.
I didn't know what
to do at that point,
but it was the
chase that was fun,
not the actual hooking up
or having a girlfriend.
This has been tried and
true for me my entire life.
For example, I'm excited
about VaynerSports right now
so much because everybody's
underestimating our agency.
I'm not gonna like
it as much in four years
when VaynerSports is one
of the top sports agencies.
Wine Library. Those
days when I was in--
I'm a cobra in the weeds. It's
why I like negative comments
on my social platforms.
I like when peop--
- [Michael] Yeah, it's 'cause
you always wanna be able to
prove somebody wrong,
which you can't do--
- Correct, yes,
yes. I love sticking it
to your fuckin' mouth,
and I like waiting for things.
I don't like
instant gratification.
- [Michael] Yep.
So, for me personally,
looking forward to
this vacation here.
When you are talking
about taking time off
intentionally as
part of a rhythm.
- Yes.
- [Michael] What do
you do to get
the most value
out of that time away?
I saw you lock
the phone in the safe.
- Yes.
- [Michael] And we don't see
anything else that happens
obviously, and that's the point.
But what does that look like?
- It's just focusing on,
I'm very good at,
one of the things that
I get a lot of compliments
for lately that
I never realized is
I'm in it when I'm in it.
People always talk about,
"Whoa, it's so weird on DailyVee
"when you meet somebody,
you look 'em dead in the eye,
"and you care,"
and this and that.
And I've noticed,
that is something that
I needed the
outside world to tell me.
So when I go into the
vacation, I know why I'm there,
and I wanna be there,
and I lock into either
relaxing or focusing
on family time, the end.
- [Michael] Yeah,
thank you Gary.
- You got it buddy.
- [Michael] I won't
take anymore of your time.
- No worries.
- [Michael] I unfollowed
everyone on Facebook
except for you. Even my wife.
- That was a very good strategy.
(laughing) Even my
wife. You're amazing, man.
That's very kind, thank you.
- [Michael] Love
you Gary, thanks.
- Take care, bro.
That's pretty good.
(phone dialing)
- Yeah, I think one of the
things that was interesting
about that question is
we're all wired differently.
You have to know yourself.
One of the great
things about loving the game
and anticipation
is you don't stop
for the short-term fruits.
Everybody wants the Beamer
and the watch and
the recognition--
- [Rachel] This is Rachel.
- Rachel this is GaryVee
and you're on the show.
- [Rachel] Oh my
God, okay, awesome.
I saw the New York,
New York number
and I did not
think it could be true.
But, awesome!
- It is true.
- [Rachel] Thank you very much.
(laughs) Very cool.
Well I know you're busy
so I will get to the point.
So I over the summer
started a foster dog vlog.
Very niche so think of
bringing in rescue dogs
and I document their
story which people love.
Because people love,
ya know, the sad stories
and I essentially take
those cute funny puppy memes
and dog and cat memes
that you see on the internet
and I put a story behind them.
- Okay, I like that.
- [Rachel] And so,
yeah, and so that's why I said
it's super niche, right,
there's nobody else doing that.
And so within the
first couple months
Dr. Oz actually reached out.
One of his producers wanted
me to come out to the show.
I couldn't because they needed
me to bring my foster dog
but we couldn't
figure out a way to do it
in the timing that
they needed so--
- Okay.
- [Rachel] We're still
working on other things.
I've already received
local, if you will, sponsorship.
Like all the local
pet stores that huge reach
here in Austin, Texas are like
"We love what you're doing.
"We want to give
you full exposure."
I've been on the local news--
- They want me to
come on regularly.
- Rach, Rach, Rach.
- [Rachel] Things like that.
- So what's the punchline?
What can I help you with?
- [Rachel] So I need you help to
I don't want to say that
I want to monetize, right?
But I need to figure
out what I can do with this
and I know that
you probably don't
know the answer right away--
- I know the answer.
- [Rachel] But I wanted, okay.
- I really do know the answer.
- [Rachel] Let's doit.
I want to hear it--
- Just based on the
data and the energy.
- [Rachel] Okay.
- Your strategy needs
to be holding your breath.
- [Rachel] Okay.
- What I mean by that is you are
going way to
fast to the punchline.
You need to
foreplay this opportunity.
- [Rachel] Okay.
- You're 40 seconds in!
How long have
you been doing this?
- [Rachel] Ah, six months?
- Yeah, I mean, I think
I really think you
need to build a bigger base.
Don't get confused by--
- [Rachel] Okay.
- The exposure.
Like how many,
what's your main place
where you're
sending this to, a blog?
- [Rachel] YouTube.
- YouTube, how many
views are you getting?
- [Rachel] Um, I only
have about 400 subscribers.
So I have about 25,000 views
total so far since launching.
- That ain't shit.
- [Rachel] Right.
- The end.
- [Rachel] Okay.
- So here's what's happening.
Your creative is
ahead of your reality.
- [Rachel] Okay.
- So milk every opportunity
and continue to get exposure.
And really wait and
realize that you haven't built
anything that you're
actually gonna make money on.
- [Rachel] Right.
- The end.
And by the way,
I'm giving you tough love
'cause I love you
and I want you to win.
- [Rachel] Yeah.
- You're getting tricked
by a couple of PR moments--
- [Rachel] Okay.
- In thinking that you have
scale for anything monetizable.
- [Rachel] Okay.
- So what I would do is continue
to use exposure to
build out your base.
I want you to have
more steak before you
worry about how
to sell your sizzle.
- [Rachel] Okay, so just
continue to get more awareness.
Just distribute,
distribute is what I'm hearing.
- Correct, correct, patience,
like you're way too early.
And I think a lot of
people get confused that
"Hey, there's
this thing happening.
"I need to figure
out how to monetize."
You're gonna have
short-term results
if you're thinking with
short-term strategy.
I would just try to
create more content.
Try to get more exposure.
Instead of like worrying about
how to make money on this.
So what, how are
you surviving in life?
Do you have a job,
do you, what's the--
- [Rachel] I have
a nine to five.
- Great, so I just think
that you need to continue
on the path of your 5:00,
6:00 P.M. to 2:00 A.M. hustle.
And I know that you
want to get to the place
where this is your
full-time but I promise you
the longer you
can wait the better.
- [Rachel] Okay.
- Because like,
how are you gonna--
- [Rachel] I can do that.
- Like, let's talk about it.
With 400 subscribers
and 25,000 overall views
like, where's
the money coming from
that's gonna allow
you to like monetize?
Like, who's paying?
- [Rachel] Well, I think
for me my thought is
I don't know where
I want to take it, right?
Which I know is the
worst response to have
but it kind of--
- No, no, no, first
of all it's the truth.
But it only speaks to
like, "Let's slow down".
- [Rachel] Yeah.
- If you don't know
what you're shooting after
to make money then
what the hell are you doing?
That's exactly right,
I love you for that answer
but it only
speaks that my advice
was even better than I thought.
Which is, you
need more time of doing
to maybe figure
out the opportunities
and the lanes
where you wanna play in.
- [Rachel] Okay.
- There's no
greater contradiction than
"Hey, I wanna monetize
this and figure out how"
and in parallel, "I don't
know where I'm taking this".
- [Rachel] Okay, that's fair.
- Do you see that?
- [Rachel] Absolutely.
- So I think
what you need to do is
did you see
episode 130 of DailyVee?
Like it's, "Going Down in
the DM" like DMing people?
You saw that or no?
- [Rachel] Yep, yes
and I do that non-stop.
That's how I was able to get
the contacts
that I did, so yeah.
- Go figure, it works.
(Rachel laughs)
So I want you to do more of that
before you focus
on anything else.
I want you to build
more of a foundation.
- [Rachel] Okay.
- Because if you
have a big foundation
then you've got
months and years to monetize
'cause you'll have time versus
"Oh crap, I have
to monetize now.
"Oh, that one
Hail Mary didn't work
"now I got to go
back to my nine to five."
- [Rachel] Okay,
yeah, that makes sense.
And it's where
I was going but I--
- Good.
- [Rachel] Can't believe,
didn't think you'd call
so this is awesome.
(laughs)
- Good, awesome.
- [Rachel] But
that reinforces it.
- Awesome.
- [Rachel] So thank you.
- Good luck, take care,
thanks for watching.
- [Rachel] Alright, thank you.
- Yeah, bye bye.
(phone dialing)
That was really
good because that's
the advice for so many of you.
So many people
are so excited about
that next part of their chapter.
It's like coming into the
NBA draft a year too early.
You could've had a
great career but because
you came one
year too early you had
a tough rookie year and
you couldn't transition.
You weren't a man
yet and you falter
and you didn't have it,
so many athletes--
- [Annabelle] Hello?
- Hey Annabelle, it's GaryVee.
(gasps)
- [Annabelle] God damn it Gary.
- I, I know, yes, it's
true. (Annabelle laughs)
I'm here, we're on,
what can I answer for you?
- [Annabelle] Oh my
God, so exciting, hi Gary.
- Hey.
- [Annabelle] Okay,
so my question is
my husband and
I recently started our own
real estate brokerage
in southern California.
- Love it.
- [Annabelle] And
before this though I was
a full-time Mom at
home with the girls.
- Very nice.
- [Annabelle] But, so I
find myself now having to
split my time part-time at work,
part-time with the girls.
- Super hard, super hard.
- [Annabelle] What
would you recommend
for me to do while I'm
at home half of the week?
- Meaning--
- [Annabelle] For our brand.
- From your brand, got it.
- [Annabelle] Yes.
- I think it's
producing content.
I think it's
following up with leads.
I think it's a lot of
hand-to-hand combat
that you can do
through your phone.
Your phone is your,
you know, ecosystem.
And so, first of all, when
the kids are around, like now
you need to be focusing on them.
That's why you decided to do it.
But in every nook and
cranny where there's downtime
you whip out your
phone and you start
creating content,
distributing content
DMing people like
I talked about in episode 130.
All that stuff.
- [Annabelle] Mhmmm.
- But here's what I would say--
- [Annabelle] Okay, so DMing--
- Here's what I would say.
- [Annabelle] Uh-huh.
- You're looking for tactics.
Let's level it up to religion.
What you want to do is
first not judge yourself
between you know, "Was
today a good day or bad day?"
Take it to macro, right?
- [Annabelle] Mhmmm, yeah.
And then the
tactics are creating content
engaging with people,
follow, ya know
it could be very not
sexy and not branding.
What happened
during the week where
you guys are talk, like
following up with people--
- [Annabelle] Oh.
- That you sold home to like
just good old fashioned thank
you economy work to be...
Did you read "The
Thank You Economy"?
- [Annabelle] Okay, I
read all four of your books.
- Good, reread
"The Thank You Economy".
That's the first
thing I would do.
- [Annabelle] Okay.
- Like literally
hang up, start the process
over a week in
every minute to reread it.
It's that kind of work because
I think when you're home
you could be doing--
- [Annabelle] Uh-huh.
- a lot of farming and
reinforcing the stuff that
you created from the hunting
during the rest of the week.
- [Annabelle] For, okay,
so perfect.
I just re-listened to "The Thank
You Economy" two weeks ago.
- Good, so--
- [Annabelle] So, my question
about content though--
- Yes, yes.
- [Annabelle] From home,
would I,
there's two
parts for our business.
Recruiting agents and
then services our agents
to help them get more
real estate business
from home owners.
- Service, when you're home
service your agents
24/7/365, that's farming.
- [Annabelle] Okay, okay.
- Period.
- [Annabelle] Perfect, yeah.
- No hunting, no looking for
new agents when you're home.
Because what I like
about that is, first of all
the kids could have a moment
pop up when you're hunting.
It's a lot better to be
disrupted when you're farming
than when you're hunting because
the farming is all added value.
- [Annabelle] Mhmmm.
(cell phone rings)
- I would be
calling these individuals.
I would be checking up
on them, this is an amazing
opportunity to farm.
- [Annabelle] Okay,
maybe like 15 minute
Face Timing with my agents--
- Yes, yes, yes,
three minute, like what
look what I'm doing with you!
Like I tell people all the time.
- [Annabelle] Yeah.
- Don't ask me for the
details, watch my actions.
- [Annabelle] Yes.
- I had 15 minutes
of downtime right now.
Bang out an #AskGaryVee Show,
I just gave you three minutes
of value, let's move on.
- [Annabelle] Perfect.
- Good.
- [Annabelle] That's awesome.
- Alright.
- [Annabelle] Thank you
so much, Gary.
- You got it, take care
- [Annabelle] I appreciate it.
I love you so much.
- Thank you.
- I love you too.
All right, so, you know
I went very high level there.
Farming is retention.
Perfect, she
walked right into it.
She's got a world
where she's maintaining
and helping those agents.
I like the idea of
using the home time for that
because you're
getting value every time.
Where you're hunting
you're spec'ing a lot.
It's just a much harder game.
Plus you have to meet people.
There's a lot of variables.
She can do the
farming from her home.
- [Nate] Gary?
- Yes, Nate, how are you?
- [Nate] Oh dude,
this is awesome.
- You're on the show, baby.
- [Nate] Sweet.
My question is, I
think I've tweeted you
a couple times this.
I'm a senior in
college right now.
And for me, I've taken your
advice of finishing school
'cause I want to, because
my parents, my grandparents--
- Yeah, it matters to them, yep.
- [Nate] How do
I tell my parents,
I just want to
go do for 18 months?
I've been sketching out all
these just go do and explore.
- What, they want you to get
the safe job after college?
Is that what you're saying?
- [Nate] Yeah.
- Just tell them, Nate.
You're a big boy, it's time.
- [Nate] Okay, okay.
- I mean really.
Listen, easy for me to say
'cause your dad might punch you
in the mouth, right?
I get it.
- [Nate] Yeah.
Here's what's interesting
about a lot of my advice.
It's black and white.
Like you know your parents.
Clearly your signals and
your nuances haven't worked
'cause they continue to want
you to go down that path.
They are not responding to you.
They are responding
to what they grew up with
and what they
believe religiously, right?
- [Nate] Yeah. Mhmmm.
- So that means the
soft way of, "Hey, maybe,"
that's not working.
Am I right?
I'm asking you.
- [Nate] Yeah, yeah,
that's totally right.
I keep getting these
lectures and all that.
- It's time for you to
lecture your parents back.
- Okay.
- One of you is
going to be right.
- [Nate] Yeah.
- Let me promise you one thing.
You really, really
don't want to be 47
and hate your parents.
- [Nate] Okay.
- Because I promise you
you're not actually hating
your parents,
you're hating yourself
for not having
the balls to do it.
- [Nate] Okay.
- You want me to come over
and have that talk with you?
- [Nate] That'd be great,
but you know...
- You think you got this?
- [Nate] Yeah, I'll give
them a call right after this.
- Dude, call them right
now and tweet me how it went.
- [Nate] Okay.
- You know I'm literally, since
Chris isn't doing anything,
he's going to bother
you the rest of the day.
Listen, let me pump
you up a little bit more.
I will be your corner man.
- [Nate] Yeah, okay.
- You start with, "Mom," or,
"Dad," or whoever you get,
"I love you, I love you."
- [Nate] Okay, yeah.
- "I'm 23 years old, 22 years old.
"Once I'm done with
this, I did this for you
"now I have to do
something for myself.
"It's high risk, high reward
but when you're 23
"that's what you do
'cause I'm not going to be able
"to do this when
I'm 47 because it's not
"going to be practical.
"It is practical, Mom
and Dad, for me for 18 months
"to just go and do
and discover myself.
"I've been doing the
thing for you my whole life.
"It's time that I do
something for me.
"And if you can't
support me in that, that's fine,
"I'd prefer you do but
I've got to do this as a man."
- [Nate] Okay, yeah.
- You don't sound
pumped enough, Nate.
What are you scared of?
Talk to me, help me.
This is why I'm
doing the call-in show
because the old show I
would have done your tweet,
I would have answered it,
I would have felt great
and then you
wouldn't have done it.
I can feel that
I've almost got you there
but I'm telling you now I don't
think you're going to do it
and if you're going to do it,
you're going to
do it half-assed.
So help me here.
Listen, I'm on your team.
Help me here understand
what you're scared of.
Tell me, tell me the truth.
- [Nate] Okay, yeah, so
for me just because of like
the pedigree and how much
education, they've sacrificed,
having a safe job so
I can do what I want,
I don't want to disappoint
them if that makes sense?
- Nate, Nate, Nate.
Nate, let me help you here.
Disappoint for 18 months and
then make them feel good again.
- [Nate] Okay, okay.
Just tell them, "I love you,"
that means you're appreciative
and you love your parents.
Tell them the truth.
Start with that.
"I don't want to,"
Like either your parents love
you and will respond to you
or they love you but
they're so deep into structure
and it's been their
whole religion their whole life
that they're incapable
even though they love you
to break through and
see it a different way.
The problem is,
it's your fucking life
and it's going to end
up one way or the other.
- [Nate] Wow, yeah, that
just broke through, yeah.
- Like it's not that
they're, right, you've just
got to tell them,
"I don't want to let you down,"
and just remind them,
it's only 18 months.
Tell them for the next
fucking 60 years you can do
the safe thing that
makes them feel great.
You need 18 months.
Can they give you 18 months?
All you want is 18 months.
- [Nate] Yeah, yeah, yeah,
and I wrote down the date.
November the 12th, 2018.
- Sign a fucking
bullshit contract.
Give yourself 18 months
and then show them.
- [Nate] Okay.
- Are you going to do it now?
- [Nate] Yep, I'm going to
hang up and call right now.
- Help me understand
who's going to be more critical.
Who is more scared of this move?
- [Nate] My mom.
- Okay, just go there, man.
Say, "Mom, I love
you with all my heart.
"I'm so thankful
for your sacrifices.
"All I need is 18 months.
"I can't live with this regret
in my 30's, 40's, or 50's
"'cause I'm going
to crack and
"I'm gonna be a broken man.
"I need 18 months and I
promise if I can't get traction
"I'll go wherever the
hell you want me to work."
- [Nate] Yep, yep, that's good.
I'll give them a call right now
and I'll tweet
you in 20 minutes.
- Give it to me.
Make me a video.
I want the video,
I want to see your face.
I don't want the words.
All right,
I love you, good luck.
Do it!
- [Nate] Bye.
- Alright, bye.
- The call-in show format gives
us so much more opportunity
to do it the right way.
Is that it?
Do you think that's it?
- [Eliot] I think so.
- Alright.
Dunk can't, show Dunk.
No, no.
- I want to do another one.
I just think it's,
you've done five.
- Listen, Dunk likes structure.
He doesn't like
to take those risks.
- [Eliot] I'll give you 18 months.
- Give me 18 months, Dunk,
just give me 18 months.
Love you guys.
Question of the day,
what is the thing you fear
the most in conversation
format right now?
Just like that amazing
call right now with Nate.
What is the one conversation
that you're most scared
to have in the world?
Do you want to break
up with your boyfriend?
Are you scared of
your parents judging you?
Is it your best friend's
dropping out of school,
changing jobs, while
still having a big college loan?
I'm just curious.
For the ones that are brave
enough to leave in the comments
on Facebook and YouTube,
will that be the liberation
by putting it out because
so many of you are losing
'cause you're keeping your
fears and you're poisons inside
and literally just
putting it out publicly,
even with an
anonymous handle on YouTube
and definitely if
you do it on Facebook,
maybe that is the
unlock in that pipe
that break in the pipe
that opens up your life.
I promise when you put out
your fears out loud, you win.
I always think about this.
It's the self-deprecation
of battle rap, right?
The reason Eminem
wins at the end of 8 Mile
is he puts out all
his laundry which leaves
the other guy nothing.
When you put out
your fear to the world,
your insecurities, you win.
You keep asking questions.
I'll keep answering them.
(hip hop music)